it's been the position of the United
States Department of Justice under
Republicans and Democrats in a 1973
memorandum and an October memorandum
under the Clinton administration that
you must not cannot indict these sitting
president not that this president would
be that's not my point
as a matter of constitutional
interpretation for 44 years that's been
the position of the Department of
Justice we've had law professors
homeless people would be law professors
all over TV and radio talking about
obstruction of justice we've had media
types talking about it we've had members
of Congress talking about it it doesn't
matter the official position of the
Justice Department is we don't charge a
city president with a crime all right
the great one Mark Levin on our program
June 20th 2017 he worked as ed Meese as
chief of staff ed Meese was the Attorney
General explaining Department of Justice
policy we've been saying this forever on
this program mark broke it right here
joins us now host of CR T V Levin TV and
life liberty and Levin the number one
show on Sunday night's great one Mark
Levin how are you my friend you know I'm
I'm getting really ticked off because
you're right you have all of these
people yesterday all big news oh they
can't indict a sitting president no
kidding
you've been saying it for over a year
we've pointed it out repeatedly the
media's gotten every aspect of this
wrong they have ignored the real crime
the real abuse of power and corruption
scandal in this country and they've been
on a witch-hunt
that is now going on over a year and to
me this has to come to an end and some
truth needs to come out sir the Muller
investigation oddly enough Shawn has
disclosed has revealed that the greatest
perpetrator of against the American
people was the federal government the
greatest perpetrator against the
American people was the federal
government was the FBI the CIA National
Intelligence director and this is a
conflation of course not and I want to
take this to the next level because the
present United States will not be
indicted and if he
is he'll take you to the Supreme Court
in a win all that said now we cannot
allow this to happen again
we saw our federal government used by
the prior administration by the head of
the CIA by the head of the FBI by the
head of National Intelligence and many
many others used to try and destroy the
candidacy of an opposition candidate in
another party Donald Trump in the
Republican Party that is the president's
administration the existing
administration interfering in the
elections we've never seen anything like
this before in American history so
here's what we need to do we now know
that the Obama administration spied spot
look it's the Obama administration he's
the president the buck stops at his desk
he may be playing around with his
library in Chicago and gone off and and
writing a phony book and everything
he's to be held responsible and his
surrogates are to be held responsible
the FISA Court failed us the FISA Court
failed us we have these National
Security Letters that are supposed to be
used in extreme circumstances being used
we have a cabal of FBI agents who took
it upon themselves to investigate a
candidate in his campaign and then we
have of course actual spies one or more
in the Trump campaign what the hell is
this the Soviet Union venez well it's
the United States of America so let me
say this once mr. Muller mr. Muller
turns over his report to mr. Rosenstein
the President of the United States
should do two things he should pick his
favorite United States Attorney not
favorite because their past but the most
professional most competent most
aggressive he can and give him an
assignment I don't care what Jeff
Sessions does he's the president and
tell him I want you to investigate the
activities that took place in this
election let the chips fall where they
may the interference in this election by
the FBI the CIA the National
Intelligence I want to know what Brennan
did I want to know what clapper did I
want to know what Comey did not because
I'm going to punish them you'll make
determinations about this right
something something is terribly wrong
more I also would tell him and I've said
this before myself we need to fix this
we cannot have
election where the federal government
our United States government is fair
interfering with an election and so what
I think the president needs to do is
appoint a commission of five or seven
people I told you this on your show a
long time ago top-notch men from prior
administration and women and appoint
them and say fix the FBI at the top fix
the CIA fix the intelligence agencies we
cannot allow this to happen to another
president United States
the hell with sorry Jeff with Jeff
Sessions and all these other people the
president should take the responsibility
on a cèlle job it's talking about you're
talking about spies in the Trump
administration you're talking about
Mauri failed FISA Court this is
incredible stuff you talk about the
spies you talk it wasn't just one FISA
Court judge that was given phony
information that was never verified
never corroborated never were they told
that Hillary bought and paid for this
information with a foreign agent where
are the where's Congress
why won't Congress bring for these FISA
judges before them and demand to know
how they feel about we lied to I'll tell
you why because unlike the Democrats the
Republicans scatter like rats they
scatter you have certain Republicans who
thrown with the Democrats because they
want to destroy this president they
can't get over the fact that he got
elected and they can't get over the fact
the American people didn't follow them
the American people don't even know who
they are but I want to emphasize
something here so your guests in the
future can repeat what I'm going to say
which is this
we need an accounting of what mr.
Brennan did and what mr. clapper did I
was what mr. book salesman call me did
we need an accounting of what Susan Rice
did of what Samantha Power's did we
haven't even gotten into the unmasking
stuff yet not because we want to get
even because we need an accounting
people need to be held to account number
one number two run Mart we fix these
departments and agencies mark if we
don't fix it we lose our country that
it's not a joking it's not a joke you
once wrote
a post constitutional America it's
getting scary now
all right great one life liberty live in
don't miss it Sunday nights 10:00
Eastern here on Fox